dix sept mille trois cent quarante cas
confirmés du coc u19 en russie dans 5478
un moscow la pandémie du coronavirus bat
son plein pour le président russe
vladimir poutine le danger du virus est
loin d'être écartée il s'agit de loeb
une nouvelle époque malheureusement le
coronavirus n'a pas reculé et constitue
toujours une menace importante
il est probable qu'en tel contexte
alarmant ne fasse que renforcer chez
beaucoup de gens le sentiment qu'une
époque complètement différente commence
que nous ne sommes pas seulement au
seuil de changements radicaux mais que
nous traversons une aire de mouvements
tectoniques et cela dans tous les
domaines de la le de 10 millions de
tests de dépistage du coronavirus ont
été réalisés à moscou et centre ou de
l'épidémie en russie malgré la hausse
des chiffres des nouveaux malades le
maire de la capitale sergueï sobianine
s'est dit encouragé par le
ralentissement de la prolifération du
virus selon la dynamique des
contaminations des hospitalisations de
la hausse des pneumonies causés par le
coronavirus et sur la base d'un certain
nombre d'autres indicateurs
on constate que cette dynamique diminue
de semaine en semaine sur certains
indicateurs la hausse se situer entre 50
et 60% puis 30% la dernière semaine
elle a atteint 15% cette semaine
j'espère qu'elle ne sera pas au dessus
cela signifie que l'épidémie ralentit
au total la russie compte presque un
million et demi de cas détectés du
coronavirus dans 85 région avec vingt
cinq mille cinq cent vingt cinq
personnes décédées des taux qui reste
largement inférieur aux états unis et
aux pays développés de l'europe